quelques petites règles à respecter pour
se régaler sans se brûler voire même de
commencer s'il y a des enfants autour
éloignez-les et tenez la distance
jusqu'à ce que le barbecue soit éteint
assurez-vous que votre barbecue est bien
aux normes de sécurité et choisissez
bien l'endroit où vous allez l'installer
il faut que le terrain soit bien plat
pour que l'appareil soit stable à l'abri
du vent et bien dégagé pour pas mettre
le feu autour de soi ne vous mettez pas
sous un arbre ni à côté d'une haie ni à
côté d'une maison ou trop proche de
matériel qui restera de s'enflammer
c'est d'autant plus important de bien
choisir son emplacement qu'une fois que
le barbecue sera allumé il faudra
surtout pas essayer de le déplacer
choisissez bien votre tenue aussi pas de
vêtements pas de manches longues et
plutôt du coton surtout pas du
synthétique parce que quand ça brûle ça
fond et ça colle à la peau prévoyez des
gants de cuisine une fois allumé ne
ravivé jamais le feu avec un liquide
inflammable comme de l'essence ou de
l'alcool à brûler et garder toujours à
portée de main de quoi éteindre les
flammes si besoin comme un saut ou un
jet d'eau pour le surveiller et pour
surveiller les gens qui sont autour ne
vous éloignez jamais trop du feu pas
trop près quand même une fois que vous
avez terminé éteignez bien votre
barbecue et restez vigilant tant qu'il a
pas complètement refroidi